hello this is Hank green and you are
watching truth or fail it is a very
simple interactive YouTube game show
where I just give you two statements and
you click on the one that's true or you
fail if you're watching this at some
unspecified point in the future I hope
that you will need reminding about the
balloon boy thing the balloon boy thing
was when that dad pretended that his son
was in the balloon thing when really his
son was in the Attic and everybody knew
he was in the Attic but they wanted it
to be a big story so that they could
land a reality TV show because everyone
knows that being on a reality TV show is
the one certain path to true and final
happiness well in my world that just
happened and we are all clamoring to
figure out how we got the wool pulled
over our aisles how we've been fleeced
and hornswoggled and hoodwinked and
every other freaking ridiculous verb but
I'm here to tell you folks people when
to fool and people since time began and
so this is the hoax edition of truth or
fail round one Edgar Allen Poe didn't
just convince the world that some guy
had flown in a gas-filled balloon over
the Atlantic Ocean when no such thing
had happened he was actually a serial
hoaxster and tried to fool people in the
news media at least six times during his
life or fact - during the 25th
anniversary of the opening the Statue of
Liberty a little girl convinced everyone
that she had lost her monkey on the
Statue of Liberty and they closed the
Statue of Liberty for two days looking
for the monkey before she told them that
she was making it all up
you